is it permissible to use toothpaste whil
fasting as far as using toothpaste is
concerned most of the scholars say that
using toothpaste is permissible
including shik bin
Bas may Allah have mercy on him he says
that using toothpaste along with
toothbrush is like using
Sak and the prophet has never prohibited
using Sak it's perfectly all right it
doesn't break the fast but it will be
careful that you should not swallow any
of it the swall any part of the
toothpaste is forbidden that's the
reason some Scholars say Mak thinking oh
if someone has toothpaste that has a
strong taste and someone SWS so that the
reason some say it's discouraged but the
right ruling is that as long as you're
careful that you don't swallow any part
of it you can use a toothpaste and a
toothbrush it does not nullify your fast
okay